today on cnbc mike novogratz went on and
had a number of really great points but
one of the things that he said that i
found really interesting was he
specifically talked about the idea of
bitcoin having won the monetary asset
race bitcoin has become that digital
gold that secures store of value on a
global stage then he talked about other
technologies are now competing for who
is going to win on the technology
platform side so we're gonna play this
video from squawk box this morning where
mike's talking about it and then we'll
explain a little bit deeper about what
exactly he's saying here
we
you know we have people wanting us to
mention this coin that coin this asset
that asset and it's hard to even keep
track at this point mike and what are we
supposed to think about that these
aren't all bitcoins not all of them have
the the future
of bitcoin is it is it the wild wild
west and does it remind you of pets.com
i mean are some of these things going to
hurt people and
i think you need to be pretty careful
the simplest way i break it up is
bitcoin is digital gold i think it's won
that lane i think it will continue to be
adopted and it will take more and more
of gold's market cap right now it's
about 12 percent of gold i think it'll
get to 100 over over a few years and so
bitcoin's got it so lame then kind of
ethereum solana luna cosmos algorand all
of those are vying to be a part of the
technology play the blockchain where
things get processed right and so we
call those level one solutions uh those
are really technology vets and we've we
invest in them based on adoption how
many people are using them how good is
the product how good is the community
and then the third bucket is stuff built
on top and so this has gone from being
just a macro trade right go long assets
to kind of a long short equity trade as
well
pick the right protocols uh and have a
methodology on why you think some things
are going to be better than others and
so it is you know
it's not for the faint of heart because
there's a high volatility uh asset class
because it's so new but it's also you
know my advice would be stay simple
unless you've got a whole lot of time
and expertise to understand the
difference between one point in the net
so when we look at this right here he's
explicitly saying that one bitcoin has
won the monetary asset it basically has
become that global store of value
bitcoin is money and when you have a
store value and a medium of exchange you
win that category but all of these other
assets he's explicitly saying is not
competing to be money nobody is sitting
at a central bank somewhere or in an
institution and saying you know what we
need to have an inflation hedge and
therefore we should actually not buy
gold or we should not sit in treasuries
instead we should go buy one of the long
tail assets nobody's saying that and so
mike very explicitly here is saying that
uh everyone is looking at bitcoin as the
winner in that monetary asset category
but again all of the other assets are
vying for to be part of the technology
play and many of them are not going to
work some of them will work the market
will determine who wins and who loses
but i think it's important to separate
out and have this idea of decoupling
bitcoin is separating itself from what
it's going after versus many of the
other technologies on top of that
bitcoin is actually also separating
itself and continuing to show that it's
non-correlated to traditional assets as
well so stock market down bitcoin up
ends up being actually a very positive
thing the more decoupled we can get both
bitcoin being decoupled from things
going after the technology platforms but
also bitcoin decoupling itself from the
traditional assets ends up being a
positive the more non-correlation the
better because what it does is it
provides very specific kind of criteria
for an investment portfolio but also it
means that bitcoin will move from a us
dollar exchange price based on different
variables it won't just be susceptible
to interest rates or gdp uh or any of
those types of kind of more traditional
movers of prices and so when we look at
this how accurate do we think mike's
perspective is and like is this a good
development or is this something we
should be concerned about in the
industry concerned about what part of it
the separation between bitcoin as kind
of going after the monetary asset versus
the technology platforms yeah i think
it's fine to separate him i don't have a
problem with that i think like his uh
when you hear him and other people kind
of industry leaders talk about what
bitcoin can be right i think the safe
thing to be honest like it sounds kind
of crazy to say but the safe thing is to
revert back to uh it eclipsing gold's
market cap right and just becoming the
digital gold right and if you look at it
when i think he said it was 12 of gold's
market cap right now
10x from now uh puts us around 500 000
per bitcoin kathy wood mentioned that
the other day uh mike novogratz has
mentioned that a bunch of other people
have mentioned that that's kind of like
the safe case at this point right and
then anything on top of that if it
becomes a a medium of exchange if it
becomes bigger than gold if it becomes
all these other things you can see how
the price can go much higher but i think
uh it's interesting that he's starting
to kind of separate the two from the
network and the actual asset but it
doesn't surprise me necessarily john
what do you think yeah more people i
think need to separate the asset from
the actual underlying technology and
they're both very important for
different um different things but the
correlation i can see it being
correlated based on the fact of if
people aren't spending money they're not
putting their money into bitcoin or any
asset for that matter um use it as an
inflation head and
a store of value but it's also a medium
of exchange so you'll start to see
people um using it kind of as as a
currency right
we'll we'll see what happens i think i'm
obviously very bullish on it i i don't
see it really it's not really that
correlated but all the cryptocurrencies
together are being called they have been
very correlated but i think we're
starting to see a little bit of
decoupling there one of the pieces that
uh some folks the bitcoin community
don't like uh some people in the long
tail assets they don't like is when you
decouple these assets bitcoin is very
clearly going after money and when you
have that strong secure global
decentralized open monetary network you
can do all sorts of things with this
store value medium of exchange you can
build on top of it with smart contracts
etc that long tail of assets though i
always go to something like nfts right
nfts don't necessarily need to be
decentralized nfts don't necessarily
need to be uh on one specific platform
or another uh there's different criteria
for what makes that valuable versus what
bitcoin's going after and the needs it
has for decentralization and security
but that also doesn't mean that uh nfts
are a scam or any other way um doing
something that is nefarious or malicious
etc right when you go to build a piece
of technology what do you do you look at
all of the technological uh
technological infrastructure that's
available i need a database what
database options are there what am i
going to use i need cloud computing okay
i might use google amazon something else
right i need to actually have this be
written in some sort of uh
scripting language what language do i
want to use all of these different
decisions get made and they ultimately
get made for either technical
superiority efficiency cost or
familiarity those are the four things
right it's either this database
technology is more effective than some
other database technology it's either
lower cost or uh um or it's more
efficient or it's just hey i know a
certain language i don't know the other
languages so i'm more familiar with it
or i i previously used that database
technology or previously used that
computing platform before and so
therefore i'm going to continue to build
for it because that's what i'm familiar
with but to me that is the big
difference here is when you separate it
away you can have monetary maximalism
right the piece that i wrote a couple of
weeks ago was monetary maximism everyone
is a monetary maximalist if you live in
the united states and you get paid in
dollars you save in dollars you invest
in dollar denominated assets and you pay
your taxes in dollars you are a u.s
dollar maximalist your entire life is
denominated in dollars and based in
dollars you think in dollars you're a
monetary maximalist but if all of a
sudden you then go into the digital
world you may actually get paid in
bitcoin you may save in bitcoin you may
actually denominate the investments you
make in bitcoin etc and so when you
start to look think of this shift is the
natural end state for money is that you
are a maximalist very few people walk
around the world and like oh i have 20
of my uh net worth or liquid portfolio
in uh um dollars i have another 20 in
euros have another 20
in yen another 20 in wands et cetera no
of course not you have one currency
you're a monetary maximalist that's what
bitcoin is vying for bitcoin has done
that to a very very successful degree